[Musique]
le président du Département Cyril
Melchior recevait au palais de la source
ce vendredi 6 octobre le président de la
Fondation Charles de Gaulle Hervy guéar
également président du département de la
Savoie après un entretien privé entre
les deux homologues Hervé Guemar a mené
une conférence intitulée de Gaul et
l'outreem devant un public venu en
nombre on veut de président du
Département c'est que l'histoire ne soit
pas méconnue
par nous-mêmes mais aussi par les jeunes
générations parce que c'est à partir de
cette histoire commune que nous pouvons
tracer notre avenir donc c'est pour cela
que laavenue de HERV guemard est pour
nous importante et moi je voudrais que
chaque personne présente à ces
conférences puissent participer à la
diffusion et bien de toutes ces
informations autour du général de Goul
parce que l'histoire de France s'écrit
aussi à travers les autres mèes et bien
évidemment aussi par la Réunion une
venue initiée par l'association Le
goulis smoker présidée par René Paul
Victoria qui intervient à la veille de
la commémoration du 70e anniversaire de
la première visite du général de Gaulle
à la Réunion le 7 octobre
1953 d'abord Charles de Gaulle a un lien
avec la Réunion puisquil est venu ici à
deux reprises en 53 alors qu'il
était rien du tout si je puis dire et en
59 comme chef de l'État et surtout de
Gaulle a compris l'importance de
l'outrem en 1940 donc s'il n'y avait pas
eu ces ralliments de Gaulle aurait été
seul ou presque dans un bureau à Londres
et ça il ne l'a jamais oublié et il n'a
jamais oubli non plus que dans les
années 50 quand il a fait sa traversée
du désert il a reçu ici à la Réunion un
accueil
incroyable qui lui a redonné la force
d'espérer donc à de prise dans sa vie on
peut dire que de GA doit tout à l'outr
français cette conférence fut l'occasion
pour cyil mchor de rendre hommage à
André Maurice P et Marc Gérard de
figures du gaulisme à la Réunion décédé
cette
[Musique]
année